bitte bedenken video what you're dead
youtuber im juli zwei wochen erscheint
der neue präsident der vereinigten
staaten von amerika amerika zuerst
amerika wird der patriotisch und von ihm
auf der ernst gemeint allerdings hat
eine late night show in den niederlanden
ein bisschen hoch genommen und war haben
die niederländer ein video raus für audi
nehmen sie gesagt haben ja ok america
darf sein allerdings wollen wir dass die
niederlande als zweites kommt und die
video im kumulierten auf zahlen von über
50 millionen und das mich einbürgern
mitbekommen hat deswegen eine aktion
gestartet die besten late night show und
außerhalb der usa machen mit und seiten
wie youtube randvoll mit irgendwelchen
länder video die sage noch weniger
verdienen würde deutschland bei den
realen oder spanien und da hab ich bin
jetzt einfach so gedacht was ich bin mit
luca mit mir diverse mit america first
und luca weckend verbreitet den hashtag
luca second überall auf youtube und
allen anderen netzwerken und jetzt bitte
message for german youtuber
computerexperte predator bis zu den
zuwächsen video war luke kibet youtuber
im juli weniger bekannten europe
lux vide oder gewaltvideos in the world
and everyone that i can t shirt über
kredite und leitungen wegen die flüge
aus der happybet manager wenn dir ob du
gemeinschaft in die pampa oder vor
diverse titel bord lautet wer wünsche
cool wie computer ist groß mit lisa
vitting gravatar
luca hat die webentwickler tagen europe
die upload grape activ jährige war wie
eine typische american world airways
lukas second lücke auf erreichte mit
great ihr müsst die panel auf die fische
bergauf american apparel lücke second
bitte bitte nicht das ganze mit humor
ist wirklich einfach nur gewinnen und
haye alle möglichen länder und make
gegen die ganze rede von ihm damit noch
die flügel aber deutschland machen oder
die holländer oder einfach gemacht ich
hoffe ja humor wenn es euch gefallen hat
dann hat man leicht da und wir sehen uns
im nächsten video wieder
[Musik]